[Music]
let's face it we live in a 24-hour news
cycle there's so much breaking news it's
really kind of hard to process at all so
we found a way to put the day's news in
perspective with the help of one of our
writers Deon Cole let's do it right now
all right let's demand the the World Cup
is underway many coaches have banned
their players from having sex during a
tournament saying it could affect their
game was Wilt Chamberlain one of the
greatest basketball players of all time
yet yes he was and didn't yes sex with
22,000 women that's that's what they say
yeah let those players have sex three
times a day and coaches
[Music]
in other news Iraq is on the brink of
Civil War conservatives are blaming
Obama for creating this mess by
withdrawing US troops did Obama get us
into Iraq I know no we did are these
critics the same guys that got us into
this mess in the first place
yeah I'm not smart then they should go
over there and clean up the whole mess
and tell them to shut the hell up a
federal trademark office ruled that the
term Washington [ __ ] was disparaging
to Native Americans but team owner Dan
Snyder is appealing the decision so he
can still call his team the Redskins was
this nighter by a team called the Boston
Irish pasty skins now he went now with
his sponsor a demolition derby and call
it driving like Asian person no he would
do that they changed the name of the
rest is that tell them to shut the hell
up
[Music]
and finally this week marks the 20th
anniversary of OJ Simpson's slow speed
police chase through Los Angeles there's
footage of that famous chase now critics
say that 20 years later all this
emphasis on the chase video trivializes
the underlying crimes didn't that chase
bring the country together yeah I did
yeah wasn't the hard to stop watching it
while it was happening it was yeah isn't
it because there's something compelling
about watching a black man moving slowly
across no TV screen
right
you
here at the end we'll tell them critics
the Shep
you